they've been coming whichever way they
can bus plane freight train
migrants from Central South America and
Beyond are heading to the U.S border
at least some of them because this week
marks a big change in U.S migrant policy
the end of title 42 a controversial
measure that the United States has used
to refuse Asylum to most migrants for
three years on the grounds that they
might carry covid
it finishes on Friday but there's
confusion among those at the border over
whether the change in rules will
actually make it easier to get into the
US
an impromptu Camp has sprung up in the
shadow of the border wall in Sierra
Juarez Mexico we met Juliana and her
daughter Emily from Venezuela on their
way in
we've got to get in today tomorrow they
could refuse us because title 42 ends
and the new rules begin
many more here think the same they've
been queuing for days it seems that the
messaging from the US has percolated
down to the ground American authorities
have been at pains to say that just
because title 42 with its near blanket
ban on Asylum Seekers is ending that
doesn't mean that there's an open border
they're bringing in other rules those
looking for Asylum have to make an
appointment here in Mexico through an
app called cbp1 and people who jump the
fence looking to hand themselves in on
the other side as has happened in the
past could face up to five years ban of
re-entry to the states or even
prosecution
but there are a lot of glitches in the
new system the CBP one app is up and
running but migrants say it regularly
crashes the second step on the app just
doesn't open Juliana told me
and despite the new rules the US is
still expecting a surge On the Border
Michael who we met on the train until
Juarez explain why
like all migrants were looking for a
better future not to be treated as kings
but to be given a chance
U.S officials estimate that there are 22
million displaced people in the Americas
many of those heading to the states
would Echo that
John Holman Al Jazeera Sierra Juarez